Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Oui, je suis pieds nus.
Défi relevé, donc ça, c’est fait.
Moi, je vais vous parler de vous.
Enfin de ce que vous produisez, de ce que
l’être humain produit et ce, toute sa vie.
C'est une chose qui peut paraître simple,
mais qui est hyper sophistiquée.
Elle pousse sur nos têtes.
Vous l’aurez compris,
on va parler de vos cheveux.
Je disais que l’homme
en produit toute sa vie,
ce n’est pas vrai pour tout le monde.
Chaque jour, un million de Français
vont se faire couper les cheveux.
Et cette matière-là, inépuisable,
en majorité, est jetée.
C’est vraiment dommage
car en France, c’est 4000 tonnes
de cheveux, chaque année,
qui ne trouvent pas de seconde vie.
On s’est dit que
c’était véritablement dommage
et qu’il fallait agir tout de suite :
retirer le cheveu du circuit des déchets
pour le transformer
en une véritable ressource.
Certains l’avaient compris
déjà bien avant nous.
Le peuple mongol, par exemple,
il y a plus de 5000 ans,
utilisait déjà leurs cheveux
pour isoler leurs yourtes.
Déjà.
Ça ne s’arrête pas là.
Au contact du sol,
le cheveu est 100 % biodégradable.
Donc on peut aujourd’hui créer
des tapis de paillage en cheveu
qui remplacent les produits plastiques
qu’on peut voir dans nos cultures,
ces grosses bâches noires pas très jolies
qu’on peut voir sur nos paysages.
C’est aussi une alternative
à la fibre de coco,
dont le bilan carbone laisse à désirer.
Et la nature ?
C’est de la nature.
La nature est tellement bien faite
qu’un tapis de cheveux sur le sol
permet de réduire l’apport en eau,
C’est utilisable en agriculture
biologique, dans votre jardin.
Ça participe également à des projets
de reforestation de la planète.
Je m'explique.
On vient entourer les plantations
d’arbres de notre tapis de paillage,
ce qui leur permet de bien se développer
et de pouvoir donc créer
les futurs collecteurs de carbone.
Le cheveu a également
des propriétés absorbantes.
Il absorbe jusqu'à huit fois
son poids en hydrocarbures.
C’est donc un excellent absorbant naturel
dans des contextes de marées noires,
de zones portuaires polluées, par exemple.
Ce qui est souvent utilisé
encore aujourd’hui,
ce sont des produits, coussins ou feuilles
absorbantes, issus de la pétrochimie.
Cela revient donc à forer du pétrole
pour absorber du pétrole.
N’est-ce pas plus judicieux d’utiliser
des produits bio sourcés ?
Nous, on croit que si.
Demain, en allant vous faire couper
les cheveux dans votre salon de coiffure,
vous allez en ressortir plus beau -
je l’espère pour vous -
mais vous allez aussi
et surtout participer
à la préservation des forêts et océans,
ce qui régule le climat aujourd’hui,
et donc à la préservation
de l’oxygène du monde.
Si on résume bien, l'être humain est
encore une fois placé au centre du sujet
et on se rend compte que nous avons
les solutions d’aujourd’hui ou de demain,
à la fois dans nos têtes,
mais aussi et surtout...
sur notre tête.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)